better cards from arrow and you're about
to watch a very fun interview between
the two of us for all you arrow fans who
are tuning in right now send us in your
questions we'll be getting to them in
just a little bit but Emily how are you
I'm doing well you haven't been here for
a little bit so it's so nice to see I
know thank you for having me yes it's so
much fun to bring you in this season of
arrow we are officially two episodes in
right okay that's good to know refresher
whoa especially two episodes and how are
you feeling about the season so far
I think it's intense I think it's
different I think it's new best shorts
our new showrunner who was actually been
with us since the beginning as a
writer's assistant Steven season one and
you know made her way through the show
cares so much about the storyline on the
show and the characters and has like
such a beautiful new take on where this
world is going so it's actually a very
exciting time to be a part of a show
that's been on for seven years because
it's like a newer show with the
characters that we all already love plus
you got to have a nice mini makeover oh
yeah pink haired Felicity oh yeah what
were your thoughts on pink haired
Felicity we've seen like dark dark dark
purple right that's right because we
have her college years her dark days the
shadows in the yeah you know huge she
goes blondes pretty drastic but I quite
like the pink hair Felicity was not a
fan of the pink hair she feels like
she's in hiding and she just wants to be
and free and I understand that yeah but
I gotta say mean sleep pretty good she
looked great yeah she looked great it
was a little longer too there's a little
longer tensions mm-hmm okay okay I'm
taking it but one of the things that I
really liked in this past episode and in
7:02 okay was that Oliver said as he was
hacking on a computer
my wife has taught me a few things that
moment did you read that inscription
like I did when did I you let me talk
it's probably just like a lot of Hobbes
knows
I'm like observing ya know cuz like I
see people hacking and I'm like easy I
got that and then I'm just like on like
Free People or something just like
buying online I'm just like yeah that's
good yeah I'll get that t-shirt and I
hacked my way closer Amazon order okay
good it's been seven years of you behind
a monitor feverishly hacking feverishly
is great as Felicity have you learned
any tips or tricks along the way I mean
my fingers are super fast I'm getting
definitely better at like video games
and things like that my motor skills are
quite something
but yeah I mean I tips and tricks you
know mostly they're just being able to
type at a rapid pace are you typing
actual thing you know what I'm learning
though yeah well yes sometimes but the
more I write around people on my laptop
I realize what a loud typer I am now and
it's actually becoming an issue is my
writing partner the other day was like
can you stop it and I was like I didn't
realize like I was like and I can't stop
it I don't know what to do how do you
type less loud that's not a thing I like
I chew my loud typers ya know I've worn
off all the letters on my keyboard I
hope there's like a meeting or support
group rest loud typers anonymous okay
yeah we're all together and let us know
do you type loudly tell us tell us right
now in your climate like I'm just like
imma leave um let's talk about something
that the fans are wondering if we're
gonna get this year on when are we gonna
get our Oliver and Felicity reunion I
get that he's in jail ah I would like
him to come out today oh yes interesting
have you filmed that reunion just yet
well maybe but who knows if it's in
reality or not I don't know it has it
has to happen because the crux of
Felicity's desire and main objective and
goal for the season would be to be with
her husband so yeah if that doesn't
happen then I mean she's gonna light
everything on fire just gonna go to
prison for arson this is very true I
like that she is so determined this year
like she is every year but this year
she's like no John I'm not gonna do what
you tell me to do I'm gonna go
rogue yes so as we look ahead into
season 7 where we gonna see Felicity's
mind says she continues forward well I
think her like original mindset is a
little broken because it's been sort of
jaded and and just like and
deconstructed if not completely
destroyed and I think the danger is
wandering or the danger is in has it
been completely destroyed or is it
repairable yeah anything that that is
pretty much her arc for the season is
deciding you know where where now she
like believes justice and her morals lie
and whether or not she can accomplish
that by being the person she was or does
she has to accomplish it now by being
the person that she has made herself
into yeah well and with Beth taking
control over the show this better yeah
Beth I love that we're getting these
flash-forwards
we saw flashbacks for so long what are
your thoughts on the flash boards in
seen old Roy right oh my god I'm so glad
that's out because when Colton was like
sending me selfies from set I was just I
was dying and also I mean I just I I
have no words I mean I love a silver fox
but like I hate silver for oh my
goodness I'm just beyond I think it's a
really I think it's really cool I mean
flash-forwards
I dare say this are more of a commitment
than a flashback because your storyline
has to go in a way of which you have
designed it to you know progress towards
these and how far in the future right in
in some reality I mean we're lucky in
our show lucky and destroyed it a little
bit by it that we have so many areas of
different realities because of the
universe that we've established you know
things can happen that maybe did happen
or or didn't that's the sort of reality
they live in but you know really really
committing to that type of storyline and
feeding the characters of where they're
gonna go it sort of creates the question
I mean like if if you're not there
already as it nurtures that nature that
got you there yeah very true well and
speaking of that we saw a future William
William and he made a dollar he's crazy
he's very handsome taller but he made a
comment saying that Felicity and his dad
abandoned him which we've seen in
present tense she was saving him and
putting him at a boarding school
keep him safe well children have a
different idea of abandonment clearly I
mean I wouldn't want to belittle his
story no I mean they you know they might
have in a way but I hope it would be for
his own protection it was for his own
protection
we'll see yeah I I love William I'm a
because he just wanted to go out on the
town
I did love they snuck in a little line
about his ex-boyfriend go well yeah go
Williams yeah yeah yes I love this LGBTQ
representation on arrow and more
throughout the world forever of course
um we're starting to get in some fan
questions before we start playing a
little game which Emily is excited about
from Queen Mills I'm excited all the
time and it resonated an excited level
so I'm feeling it I'm feeling it can I
yell are you guys getting yeah okay just
see every time like I yell someone's
like Queen Mills wants to know what is
your favorite Felicity outfit do you
have a favorite pants
yeah or pajamas she is always in quite a
tight dress yeah the seasons a little
different though because she's kind of
like taking action and Beth is like she
needs to let us for that I'm like yeah
she doesn't I love that and then I'm
like standing this to Giuliana and I'm
like hey myth you may be so beautiful
tall and Alice's lovely and sweet Oh
Selena wants to know what is your
favorite thing about being on the show
working with some of my best friends
every day every day and there's more and
more best friends on the arrow set right
now because it's crossover season his
crossover season which I started writing
is like EXO in my texts so I wrote the
other day I was like cuz a lot of people
a lot of the crew was ill cuz it's just
like illness season right and colds and
stuff and so I was like everyone on set
is sick because of EXO's and then my
friend I was text me was like was
everyone like making out and hugging on
set I was like oh my god no crossover
yeah like I mean everyone's just so
loving yeah can you tease if you're
sitting with me now okay mister I can
tease that this is this is lag
now a lot of your co-stars are filming
the crossover is Felicity in the
crossover she is in the crossover I just
happened to be here for day what were
your thoughts when you found out that
the crossover is that Oliver and Barry
are body switching so my mouth like in
the floor and then I had to like go and
surgically get it put back on so this is
a temporary jaw working towards getting
my original one back and I still don't
know what to do about it because seeing
that suit in Reverse is jarring and
quite special and I'm getting a lot of
behind-the-scenes footage
well you're friends with both Stephen
and Grant so okay let's break this out
thoughts on Stephen in the flash costume
it is fast so sorry sorry stunt guys
they are will who stunt Stephen in the
arrow suit a lot of the time he's
wearing the flash suit and he said to me
use like you know what's funny is you
put on the different suits people treat
you differently because the flash think
people want to hug me in the arrow suit
they want to punch me and I was like
it's true because I know you're willing
to be like ah feels like it's like the
fighting so you get so hurt in the arrow
suit he's like guys this time around you
just get hurt yeah he's like I put on
this one people are like I wanna cuddle
yeah it was like um thoughts on grant in
the arrow suit it's pretty dope yeah
right it looks awesome
yeah and grant likes to like tap dance
and move a lot so it's like nice to see
like the it like the arrow is just like
the light-hearted like twinkle toes we
are now going to play a little game what
do you get out there right now so doc
let ik um we are gonna play a game
called kiss and tell we're okay I'm
gonna be showing you three iconic
olicity kisses okay and I want you to
tell us behind the scenes secrets about
what it was like to actually film them
that day what you remember about it so
this is not seven minutes on happen this
is not seven minutes in heaven that's
that's for another day so we are gonna
start off with the first kiss right now
and
is all of our in Felicity's very first
kiss oh stop dangling me bees say it's
never gonna work out between us say you
never loved me sick
[Music]
don't ask me to say that I don't love
you
I told you since we talked
[Music]
Meredith Grey yeah but that was way back
in season three that was in the hospital
right yeah
in the hospital in the hallway okay yeah
I think because that was like our fur
like we were we were friends hmm like
we're pretty good friends too but we
were like more work friends then than
anything so we'd showed me like yeah
gonna be a good day but it was more like
that scene was more for their characters
it was more important about like it
wasn't I mean yeah I mean like a kiss
was important for the story and for but
they didn't know it was happening was
like summer I guess the future were just
like I'll eat garlic before it you know
so that one I don't remember as much
well I'm some joking around and whatnot
let's take a look at our second kiss
which is one of my favorites Oh weird
watching yourself oh I know I know I'm
sorry popper yeah I like to uh let's go
this next one this is Ivy town we
haven't seen yeah I miss Ivy town I
honestly wish that that was something
that I wish stayed around longer on TV
and happiness was interesting
[Music]
this is he smoke you have failed this
omelet really yeah it's criminal how
easily cookies can be you well I always
wanted to expand my horizons feel like I
could do any Island which is basically
just cooked in an uncooked
house your job who's good I'm good a
used to running without chasing after
someone mmm-hmm sweaty I know
amazing yeah very sweet we just have one
more kiss for you and someone say it is
the most iconic elicit kiss we're gonna
show you right now let's get this one
[Music]
[Laughter]
line forms behind me it's kind of
amazing that we've made it this far
we're gonna be fine can we be so sure
because we found ourselves in each other
oh yeah and then we humped everybody
loves humping yeah is especially
dry-humping but that was like an iconic
kiss but yes so it was it was I just was
always curious like how did you you were
laying down and that was the director
who was like well did you see I was cut
so we were there and all of a sudden we
were lying down and we just kind of came
into frame you think so if you want to
recreate that kiss for yourself I don't
think it's gonna be as romantic cuz you
gotta got to think about the position
which is why TV can be so romantic
I have a question for you how do you say
dry hump on LA on live TV probably but
I'm not gonna say I'm just gonna let you
keep saying what John have it's hump day
is it Wednesday there you go it is it's
hump day this Wednesday okay it's kind
of dry outside here we go everyone so
confused they're like let's dry humping
in Canada is it cold like what is it
Olay my favorite shades of olicity wants
to know stop it handle that is there
handle how many shades of olicity do you
think there are committed I mean happy
shades and future shade okay and prison
shades top that world-saving shades
awesome Ivy town shades and when people
die shades one more off-screen shape
okay alright so shades of illicit he
wants to know we've already seen Roy and
William in the flash-forward so far will
we be able to see old felicity and if so
how does it feel to play your old self
right wooden that'd be cool so old foot
like should it be old Felicity or should
it be like felicity like did like the
Meryl Streep like Fountain of Youth
death becomes her and she's like she's
just a real snatch back yeah real smash
back and like that 22 year old skin and
yeah like well you seen her mother her
mom looks great her mom looks great so
right
Donna I don't know there should be a
campaign this is where is Donna yeah um
Lisa says we almost happy olicity in Ivy
town and we do just commented my heart
commented my Romina Romina I know we
were dating that's so sweet
alright Oh Natasha wants to know do you
have any more fight or action scenes
this season yeah what is that like for
you do you have fun with that I have so
much fun with that because I you know
love to kick butt
not a workday yeah like why not you just
make your workday into a workout they're
good to go Lindsey Morgan and I was like
how do we make this into a work I would
be like drinking coffee we're like make
the coffee heavier just put weights on
the bottom of the mug like I don't know
I don't know how we have you thought
about getting back on the Salmon Ladder
ah the Salmon Ladder is like my what's
the word nemesis
because in my head I'm like I can do
that yeah and then I get up there and I
can't like you believe all these things
you good person I'm fed I've been of the
world and equality and then you get up
there and you can't do the Salmon Ladder
you're like none of these powers but we
have so many kick butt ladies on the
show right I know that for you thank you
oh we have so many kicked butt ladies on
the show and we have another one joining
us Katherine McNamara who a lot of fans
know from Shadowhunters yes is said to
be joining arrow wonderful have you
shared any scenes with her yet not yet
yeah I haven't met her up in Vancouver
yet but we're very excited all the fans
are super excited have they heard have
they teased anything about like who she
could be playing I want to see her like
I don't know like yeah they take on like
maybe like an iconic villain oh god be
good that's all I got so far so we'll
keep planning you fans tell us what
you're thinking we call her we should
ask her what she wants we should we
should we'll tweet her right after this
give the ladies what they want yeah the
ladies what they want um I want to know
what's coming up for you because you
have a new movie coming out I do it is
premiering this weekend at the Portland
Film Festival yes so we've done a couple
of festival circuits they're also in
Spain right now so I'm the only one from
film going to the Portland Film Fest
because everyone is in Spain during the
movie and things like that but I
couldn't how did you miss that actually
working okay you know here with you
thank you so yeah so we're sort of like
we're a little bit split this weekend in
terms and we did we were in Park City
for Slamdance
and we're just like making the circus
there it's gotten a lot of like audience
love and it's doing really well Michael
Gallagher you know shot directed and
produced it's his baby it's awesome it's
very uncomfortable
it's it's fun I mean I hope it's fun I
mean if you like be uncomfortable which
I liked
well no it's it's nice for you to be
able to step into different roles you
play Felicity for 23 episodes this
season so what is your been your
favorite part about stepping out of her
shoes into someone else's well it I
think it's interesting we did a that
shoot particularly was very short we're
doing a indie film I think we shot in 17
days and we shot it about a year and a
half ago
I always just loved you know diving into
a different story into different you
know human being and sort of being able
to relate to that person yeah everyone
has a story to tell and everyone you
know wants to be able to listen and and
I think your listening skills and
storytelling skills only get better if
you spend time around other people very
true and want to care there you so
hopefully yeah this film will help you
want to care yeah well I care about you
and I care about the play that you did
this past summer yeah talk to us about
that and and it could be see it
somewhere else we might yeah we might be
traveling with it to New York in the
summer we had some interest and we're
just trying to figure out scheduling
right now so that would be pretty
unbelievable rewarding it's written by
Zay Dorn it's a three hundred dark
comedy about a girl who makes reporting
dolls which are like very live looking
dolls which is a which is a common
practice uncommon practice but it's out
there it's out there super interesting
going into the world she's also like a
very you know dark and disturbed
character which I seem to like to play
but there's it's fast and it's comedic
and it's you end up you end up having so
much heart for these characters and I
don't know theatre is just one of the
best things on the planet yeah well I
can't wait to see you
stage again and in this new movie and
also in the rest of season seven of
arrow before we say goodbye to everyone
out there what can you tease me about
what is in store for season seven oh you
know a little spoiler little spoiler
well we all know Ruby roses on set have
you shared any scenes with Ruby I
haven't upset about that and we have
Cassandra Jean yeah exciting for me very
exciting for me what olicity goodies can
you tease from when we eventually will
get that reunion we know it's coming the
first kiss has some scars in it that
arrow is there's lots of scars so it's
true stars and hearts scars and hearts
Carson art should be the new tagline yes
all right rich engine in this garden art
we're gonna leave this right now we're
gonna see it trending on Twitter I don't
know I mean kind of sounds like the
Lucky Charms
what is the I'm not doing the end of the
rainbow
you know it's like when they list all of
the like different like marshmallows
they list the marshmallows in America
they don't do that in Canada they're
just like go eat your sugar and like
have a good day I'll show you something
oh my god yeah anyways he turns little
cereal I would pick as a kid this
explains a lot of deficiencies I could
chat with you all day okay ran out of
time I'm good I think we're good I know
you guys all so much thank you you're
watching right now be sure to tune in
every Mondays to the CW's arrow sits on
Mondays new so watch it then Emily thank
you for stopping by the shadow and we'll
see you guys soon bye
[Music]